herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
damit will ich warte auf youtube
unterwegs und hatte noch eine idee für
ein heutiges video gesucht und bin dabei
auch ein video von kers bali gestoßen
der hat nämlich einen snapshot wahrheit
oder pflicht gemacht und ich dachte mir
das ist echt cool
warum machst du das nicht einfach ja
also folgendes ich hab einfach bei sap
chef gepostet match at hat sich gar
nicht nett dass sie mir gerne fragen für
wahrheit aufgaben oder pflichtaufgaben
pflichtaufgaben stellen soll
und wir gucken jetzt einfach mal rein
was man lieber pizza oder döner dass es
sich öfter pizza was mag ich hier
schwierig für mich weil ich würde fast
sagen ich mag lieber
ich würde einfach irgend jemanden
erschrecken
okay da erschrecke ich jetzt mal
jemanden okay wer gut getroffen muss ich
sagen das machen wir natürlich sehr
gerne direkt mit milch müssen und
trinken klingt nicht so lecker aber dass
ihr okay was da habe ich schon hier
etwas immer noch milch holen und
programm
[Musik]
was ich glaube welchem vier ich beende
faultier aber immer so bei diesen ganzen
tier fragen läuft irgendwie so ein
bisschen auf dem wolf heraus bei mir ich
weiß nicht genau warum aber andere
menschen sagen immer dass ich aussehe
wie ein wolf und ich hab neufeld
[Musik]
gelocktem auf der nice wir haben bin ich
mit freunden ich würde sagen jetzt so
sechs sieben jahre vielleicht für mich
so was in den trainings das seien ganz
auf jeden fall im urlaub kennengelernt
und waren immer an den gleichen
urlaubsorten deshalb ja natürlich mit
freundschaft entwickelt auf jeden fall
ein gutes licht oder wahrheit
[Musik]
greta ist mein name ist also schauen
greta ich hab sogar auf youtube
abonniert also mit anderen worten ja
mach bestand hey warum verkaufte die
andere waschmaschine mit wahrscheinlich
habt ihr das eigentlich mit bekommen wir
welche zeitweise zwei waschmaschinen
weil eine größer war als die sein sollte
und deshalb mich durch meine tür geparkt
hat ich hab die schon längst nicht mehr
also die wurde zurückgenommen
ich habe auch das geld zurück bekommen
deshalb keine sorge ich hab nur noch
eine waschmaschine und die macht auch
mist und eben überlegen wann war das
wohl irgendwie 13 oder 14 weiblich
wahrheit hast du schon mal ein feldherr
auf dem flur gemacht also auf dem klo
und auf dem klo sah oder auf dem klo auf
der toilette wahrscheinlich direkt
auftrittsfläche auf dem blog wie keine
andere sieht man halt im zweifelsfall
wird im hintergrund rückt ich würde aber
trotzdem sagen ja aber ich bin schon am
das war mein eigenes kranarm emergent
man sehen ob es vielleicht bald das neue
feature ob es mal irgendwann was neues
gibt
wie viele freundin hab ich schon also
welche die ich rede so mehrere sachen 2
und ein politisch glaube weitere
schwierigkeit verstand wahrheit
du musst eine heizdecke ok mache ich
finds super video das man natürlich
gefällt
schmeckt wie meine halten erwarten würde
[Musik]
also erst einmal an verpacken und
bergmann immer sehr viele mauern in dem
grundlagen hab ich leider nicht da ein
löffel senf trinken auch man irgendwie
eklig ist nicht nur ein paar wahrheiten
draußen beantwortet die aber erfahren
dass eine menge und das wasser durch
löcher wahrheit standest du jemals in
seiner schulzeit auf eine lehrerin nicht
hätte ich mich erinnern könnte wahrheit
würdest du wenn zum beispiel sebastian
die einzige person auf der erde wäre
und du kein echter actionheld ist ines
ermöglicht der form also irgendwann dann
wird vom kannibalismus getrieben ist
oder einfach weil ja lieber sterben
[Musik]
ich würde sagen mit dieser frage beenden
getraut das heutige video für sehr
brisanten abschluss gerade gehört ich
würde vielleicht habe ich schon mal
einen dreier hatte und ich kann euch
sagen dass ich noch mehr